welcome back to this show a man who is
gonna be on the season 5 finale Sunday
night of ballers but a Zahn tonight on
the unicorn on CBS which is a new show
that airs every single Thursday at 8:30
p.m. Eastern on CBS and CBS all access
good to see you all Marv Miller how are
you bud great to be here a little tired
but uh it's hard oh man I've been in
that rarefied TV air constantly you're
constantly on camera on screen it's wild
do you have kids too or no no no no
about say if anybody wants to call in
callers if very good so your your um
your doing that but uh obviously I'm
assuming you're off tonight right you're
not working no I'm about to go to work
in a little bit I just snuck down shoot
a coin launch man this show can actually
do something for people well it's it's
an interesting program because it's
about it's a comedy about the lead
character Walton Goggins
he's a years removed from losing his
wife after a long marriage yeah and you
and Rob Corddry play as buddies who were
trying to encourage him to get back out
there yeah much in life in general not
just invading but in life right he's
kind of neglected himself at this point
right and so do you know anybody like
that in your real life or just you know
what I met the actual guy that the show
was based on no kidding cat named Grady
yeah he's the actual unicorn in real
life and that's how they came up with
the concept it wasn't something they
created per se now why is he called a
unicorn pretty much ah because we
actually mentioned that in the pilot
because for people on the online dating
scene this this unicorn is something
that almost doesn't exist a committed
middle-aged man who doesn't have a
problem with commitment or discipline
who's a good father has his own job and
good credit and and is also doesn't have
a lot of miles on his on his tank if you
will Adama so that sees the unit because
he's a unicorn okay as you know in the
sports world a unicorn is somebody like
porzingis and yes right or luca Donna
she's the he's the Unicorn listen five
two guys in baseball like or Cunha the
Bellinger
your guy your guy Bellinger yeah are you
from Anaheim are you not yes morning
raced in f1 razinin on him so why are
you wearing a Dodger hat oh man you know
I have a stroller too some it's deep
water this will be this will be a long a
long conversation but yeah I you know
what I kind of grew up in the in the
both because of my family business and
whatnot was all in Los Angeles okay and
now that I've moved back in at home
after school and working I'm spending
all my time in Los Angeles right and I
start working with the Dodgers on the
charity stuff when Don Mattingly was a
coach and they really embraced myself
and my brother and we've been doing
stuff with him the whole time and I was
trying to get a 10-day contract by
weighing their apparel and did mortality
nah didn't work they had a guy at for
his base it was weird there's a guy
first base yeah or he's in right field
that's the amazing thing about about
Cody Bellinger are you nervous about
these Washington Nationals coming in
tonight
I'm nervous in general I've been at
Chavez Ravine two years straight when
somebody else celebrates the World
Series on the field I'm in the front row
and it's a nightmare I don't want to see
it again I'd rather they get eliminated
early than to go to the World Series and
get the Buffalo Bills treatment there's
your guy Chris here's your unicorn right
I was there last year way too soon the
celebration was going on I left well I
left that was bad the bitter beer face
well well the thing the reason why I'm
bringing up in terms of Unicorn is just
based off of the way the Brewers just
lost their heart right so you saw that
and the fact that they went thirteen
into 13 inside without bellend without
well it's right who did is the MVP and
they do all that just to get in the
position to be judged to blow it so the
question was would you rather your team
not put that hope in you as a fan no
well we still got to make it you are the
love and lose rather than never loving
it 100% I'm a gambler you never know
couple pitches bounces you know the
right way a couple balls don't roll
under people's gloves right you guys are
facing the Dodgers and you'll probably
get swept but now we're looking at a
national series where the Dodgers better
bring their a game and we seem to have a
problem with that our stars
don't show up well Turner does though
Big Time Vault there Redbeard mani he
should usually it's this time of year
where we hear he's up there with Ruth
and Gehrig in terms of on-base basis and
in terms of getting on base in October
by the way he's an Orange County native
and he plays the game the right way
which is a baseball term you hear a lot
the Dodgers have a hard time winning
because they don't play the game the
right way right you got guys playing out
of position you're playing an analytics
game which may be good over 162 games
sample but in five and seven Series
games the series you know five and seven
series game series yes it doesn't
doesn't there's not enough space for
that you got to play the game the right
way you got to hit the ball the other
way you got to move runners you have to
play the game the right way and there's
a handful of guys who have done it they
got rid of a guy who was clutch last
year and yasiel puig so I'm very
interested to see if AJ Pollock can pick
up the slack or if the other guys that
are there can pick up the slack it's
funny Omar Miller here on the Rich Eisen
show you mentioned weeds name yeah that
you like you're genuinely concerned
about your Dodgers but the one thing is
is that Puig is not here for this time
around and you you're you're pointing
that out it's so it's a it's funny
because for one nobody talked about it
but he should have been the MVP of the
National League Championship Series last
year they gave it to Kody Bellinger and
one of those in my opinion political
things we're like you know they knew
he's the next guy and whatnot they give
it to the Unicorn they gave it to
Unicorn know they after it's just it's
it's self-preservation you know what I
mean it's smart but at the same time
last year we got his game together he
showed up now I'm not in the locker room
I don't know what's going on there where
the problems may be right I know he hit
a big bomb in the World Series that
looked like it was gonna set the Dodgers
up to shock the the monster we'll see
what happens this year they're stacked
it's not like they don't have the talent
it's about whether the talent can
execute in the big games this is what
it's about Chris could you believe that
the storyline of the 2019 Dodger season
the question the headline is Dodgers
missed week I don't believe that they
may not right fun Jim you regains form
and he can pitch to contact and pitch
his way out of situational problems then
they'll be fine he kind of fell apart
over the last month month and a half of
the season and
you're in the playoffs you were against
the big boys and pitching the contact
isn't necessarily seems like what you
need in this major league why am I
sitting here thinking maybe Seger's an
answer right they didn't have you didn't
have sugar and I tell you what segars
been back for Bellinger and if you
remember before Seeger hurts his his arm
and you go down for Tommy John's the guy
they are building the franchise around
corey seager we'll see what happens
tonight and I think he is a big-time
ballplayer actually we'll find out
Kershaw to dominate and put this just I
guess put a button on it here this is
why it kills me that the angels aren't
in the playoffs I would love to see
trout in a conversation like this and
you know I agree I mean it would be just
amazing to see him I mean it's not wait
till he's wearing pinstripes
he's never gonna wear pinstripes no the
angels won't let him go but it's the
same sign up forever he's not but at the
same time how do you keep winning MVPs
and your team never makes the playoffs
that's my point every year well he is
the best player in Major League the best
player and being the MVP preach I can be
the MVP of the Rich Eisen show but if
nobody watches it means nothing well
first of all bite your tongue let's come
up with a different analogy that doesn't
include not watching no sorry please no
I are you saying you gotta win you gotta
get to the postseason now he doesn't
pitch the game anything that that Mike
Trout is a part of he makes the team
better there's no doubt about that but
you have to win okay so we're talking
Dodgers baseball with Omar Miller again
the unicorns on tonight 8:30 p.m.
Eastern on CBS and CBS all access are
you one of the Laker fans that boos
Kawhi Leonard because he chose the
Clippers over the Lakers or you have
never been a Laker fan in my life never
once I have never done you know what
when I was a kid I came up around the
time where Magic Johnson totally and
completely dominated the NBA and but
around my age group it was all about
Michael Jordan so
I was one of those kids who loved
Michael Jordan and that automatically
puts you at odds with the Lakers and
Magic Johnson I recognize them as the
best and if I had to actually pick a
team I don't think any team that we've
seen can run with those Showtime Lakers
at all so you're not do you have an NBA
team or just you don't oh no I mean I
follow the Clippers and I would you know
I've had season tickets for a while with
Lob City uh since a lob City but I think
I may be the bad-luck charm the good
thing is I have to work tonight so I
won't be at Dodger Stadium maybe they'll
pick up a win
you're the cooler - you guys are just
lockstep he's the cooler over there I
take the Red Sox the year before games
is that the LeBron beats the Celtics
game seven in Boston ask him what was at
Game seven when when Kobe in Andrew
Bynum knows was watching with this idiot
with you and say you play the general
manager of the Los Angeles Rams on on
ballers you know to the Rams because
they play along with it which is really
nice I go to the games they told me on
the jumbotron last Sunday or two Sundays
ago less need the actual Rams was on the
show and they play along with this
really it's been a great job being on
these fields well the Rams understand
what town that their own right now there
are Hollywood so they just gonna throw
themselves into that whole mix I just
wish they would throw themselves into
the Todd Gurley mix because I drafted
him hi
and I'd like them to give him the
football McVeigh if you're listening I
mean I'm sure I'll see you at the
restaurants just slide my man the ball
McVeigh if you're listening he's trying
to collude and try to get Ukraine
against some touches for own
I don't know we were talking about it at
the top of this hour like we don't know
I think they're I think they're just
maybe holding him back first for months
so the last 12 weeks are like the first
12 weeks last year that's what I need a
plan right now with Gurley you know I
think that's the plan but I don't think
it's a good plan because as the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers showed if you don't give
him the football you will not get to
those last four weeks where they matter
he's the key to opening up the game for
Jared Goff at this point perhaps at some
point Golf becomes the guy that he can
play without the super solid running
game but until then you have the man in
the backfield give that man the ball
stuff it down people's throat until they
just can't take it anymore and they'd
submit I think that's what that's gonna
they're gonna try and do tonight I
really do because especially in the rain
well especially also the play-action
works if you think Early's got the ball
it only works if you think early has the
ball it works if Gurley runs it
effectively but they know that - I mean
McVeigh's knows more more offense in the
tip of his finger than most human beings
doing them myself included so before I
let you go Omar Miller you and Corddry
you can only do stuff with Rob's and
ballers Rob's in the unicorn - yeah
Rob's riding my coattails
you know a buddy mine but seriously dude
get your own jobs right exactly
yeah he's drafting on your Omar Miller
that's I can see that right now you know
I'm girly that's what it is what was it
like on the last day I liked it what was
it last like on the last day of the set
of ballers for you well you know what it
was anticlimactic because I was there
and I was the only series regular there
okay and yeah the show has become really
compartmentalized and we aren't in the
same group setting that we were when we
were in Miami and some people like it
more some people like it less but it's a
trip because I found out that that was
the last day that there wasn't one with
all of us together at an inopportune
time as I go alright so that's it huh
there's hell of a hell of a run though
great run and you know what it being on
a piece of art that connects that
cultural like Xena
of money and fame and celebrity and
sports it was something really special
this show has just allowed me to meet so
many different people and access to so
many different worlds that includes
Glaser to write J glaze glaze bacon kind
of kind of may eat your mandated - men
like J would be upset if I didn't
mention like that's it J has submitted
himself for several Emmys and the
submissions have come back for the
Razzies uh-huh and he's hi
he's upset that he's way up there and
the Unicorn is just a neat show again
it's about walton goggins plays Wade he
lost his wife a year prior to the show
starting and and and you play friends
were just trying to get him through life
and and it's a it's a nice warm but
funny it's pretty funny show yeah it's
really honest you know there's no laugh
track or anything like that weird it's
us it's us and you'll have to make the
verdict on whether or not you find stuff
funny or heartwarming or whatever and
you know what I think that if people
give the show a shot they'll be very
very happy that they did Thursday at
8:30 p.m. Eastern tonight and every
Thursday night CBS and CBS all access at
Omar Miller on Twitter at Omar Benson
Miller on Instagram good to see you
thank you sir come on back whatever come
on back okay come on back later on this
year
Omar Miller right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app